معنا عامر سالتك عن اهم ما جاء في خطاب
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في اسطنبول
نعم وسيله وبينما اتحدث عن اهم ما جاء
دعيني انقل لك الصوره هنا بالمناسبه نحن
يعني استغرق منا الوصول الى مقربه من بيت
الرئيس اردوغان تقريبا ساعه ونصف عنا
الطريق قصيره جدا لكن ربما لا ابالغ ان
قلت لك اسطنبول كلها كانت متوجهه الى بيت
الرئيس للاحتفال والاستماع الى الكلمه
التي القاها على مناصريه ومن انتخبوه هذا
اليوم اردوغان ربما اهم جاء على لسانه في
هذه الكلمه التي اعتبرها الكلمه استباقيه
للكلمه الرئيسيه التي سيجلي بها من انقره
قال اردوغان بدايه نعبر عن شكر وقف معه
بالتوادر الحزبيه من الشعب اعتبر ان هذا
النصر الا نتيجه التعاون
العمل المشترك بين الشعب وبين الكوادر
الحزب وبينما عملوا في انجاح الرئيس
اردوغان في هذه الانتخابات اعتبر ان هذا
اليوم وهذه المناسبه جاءت بين مناسبتين
مهمتين وهذه ربما احد يعني الرمزيات التي
ركز عليها اردوغان وسيله في الايام
الماضيه عندما قال بانها تعلمين اليوم
الامس 27 من مايو هو ذكرى اول انقلاب ينفذ
في تاريخ الجمهوريه التركيه 27 من مايو
اغد انه هو ذكرى فتح القسطنطينيه او فتح
اسطنبول غدا هو الذكرى التي تحولت فيها
هذه المدينه الى عاصمه للعثمانيين
وبالتالي كان يناشد ويطالب محبيه والذين
سينتقد بان يتوجهوا الى صناديق الاقتراع
لكي يكون هناك عيد اخر بين هذين
المناسبتين المهمتين وهو ما عاد اليوم
وتحدث عنه تحدث طبعا عن الضروره الاستعداد
وعدم الخمول ان هناك في العام القادم
انتخابات للبلديه على الجميع ان يكون حذر
ومستعد لاعاده اسطنبول الى حضن العداله
والتنميه والتحالف الجمهور ايضا ربما تحدث
عن
المجاره اليوم هو مثال حقيقي للديمقراطيه
ليشهدوا العالم ولا احد قال لاحد في
العالم اليوم يجرى ان يتحدث عن
الديمقراطيه التركيه الرئيس يخوض جوله
ثانيه مع ان كان الفارق بسيط جدا وينتصر
في الجوله الثانيه وبالتالي اراد ان يقول
للعالم بان الديمقراطيه التركيه لا يمكن
ان احد ان يمسها او ان يتحدث عنها بالصور
ايضا ربما لم لم يترك اردوغان ايضا
المعارضه دون ان يصوب اليها السومه
الانتقاد الذي اعتاد خلال الفتره الماضيه
على تصويتها عندما
تناول
كمالكولو منافسه في هذه الانتخابات عندما
قال عندما عاد ووصفه انه غير قادر على
الحسابات مع انه يتحدث عن نفسه دائما بانه
مختص في الحسابات انتقدوا عندما قال بانه
قام بتوزيع مقاعده في البرلمان مقاعدي
حزبه في البرلمان على على احزاب كل مجموعه
ما تملكه في الشارع لا يتجاوز 1 اعطاها
اربعين مقعدا وهذا ما عدا واكد عليه وذكره
اردوغان اليوم قبل قليل في حديثه من امام
منزله في اسطنبول ايضا ربما المهم ذكره ان
اردوغان وسيله وصف هذا النصر بانه ليس فقط
وصل مصر لتركيا بل هو نصر لكل المغرومين
في العالم تعلمين اردوغان يتحدث دائما عن
ان تركيا مع كل المظلومين في العالم تساعد
الجميع وبالتالي هذا النصر استمرار لمنهج
اردوغان ولمنهج حزب العداله والتنميه
ولمنهج تحالف الجمهور لا شك طبعا انه اكد
ايضا من اهم النقاط التي اكد عليها بان
هذا الفوز وهذا النصر ماذا يعني يعني قرن
الجديد تعلمين طوال الحمله الانتخابيه
السابقه كان اردوغان يتحدث عن ان انتصاره
في هذه الانتخابات يعني قرنا جديدا لتركيا
اسس للبنيه التحتيه لهذه الدوله والان
الانطلاقه نحو مستقبل باهر كما كان يردد
طوال الحمله الانتخابيه وبالتالي قال لنا
تراجع عن وعودي لكم لن اتراجع عن
الاستمرار في تطوير هذا البلد والانتقال
الى قرن تركيا وبالتالي هذا هو ما اكد
عليه ابرز ما اكد عليه ربما هناك نقطه
يعني استخدمها كثيرا رجل طيب اردوغان في
حملته الانتخابيه عندما تحدث ربما في كل
خطاباته عن ضروره الاهتمام بالعائله عندما
قال بين الاحزاب التي تنافسه هي تدعو لدعم
المثليه وتوافق على المثليه وهو امر يضرب
اسس العائله التركيه اسس العائله التي
تقوم عليها المجتمع وبالتالي قال بان هذه
الكل هذه الاحزاب التي واجهت التي تدعو
لهذه للمثليه سقطت الان لان المجتمع
التركي يريد الحفاظ على العائله التركيه
ولا يريد هذا هذه المثليه وما الى ذلك
تحدث ايضا عن المراه الاعتبار ان كل من
يتحدث في هذه الامور يصف ربما ان نهج
العداله والتنميه بانه يسهل للمراه قال
بان الاسلام وديننا يمنعنا تماما عن اهانه
المراه يحفزنا على احترام المراه وبالتالي
نحن على هذا الطريق ندعم المراه مع كل
نساء تركيا ومع كل نساء العالم وسيله ربما
هذا اهم ما جاء في خطاب اردوغان قبل ان
يعلن بانه سيتوجه الى انقره ربما هذا
الانتصار انتصار اقول بانه السابع عشر في
تاريخ رجب طيب اردوغان منذ ان فازوا في
عام 2002 بعد ان اسس حزبه باقل من عام دخل
الانتخابات الاولى في عام 2002 وانتصر
وخلال 21 عاما الان هذا هو الاستحقاق
الانتخابي السابع عشر الذي يفوز فيه
اردوغان
لم ينتصر في اسطنبول نعم فارق ضئيل لكنه
ايضا لم يتمكن من الانتصار في اسطنبول كسر
قاعده جديده قائمه دائما كان الاتراك
يتحدثون وسيله عن ان من ينتصر في اسطنبول
ينتصر في تركيا لم يحقق الانتصار نعم فارق
بسيط لكنه لم ينتصر هنا في اسطنبول لكنه
فاز بكل تركيا وهذا دعينا نقول انه ان صح
وصفه رقم قياسي لهذا الرجل الذي جاء من
بلديه اسطنبول حكم بلديه اسطنبول عام 1994
ومنها انتقل ليصبح حاكما لهذه البلد
ويستمر في الحكم ل 21 عاما الان هذه
الانتصارات المتتاليه اعتقد بانها ستطرح
الكثير من التساؤل عن مصير تحالف المعارضه
في الايام القادمه الجميع سيتساءل عن مصير
تحالف المعارضه وعن مصير
كمالك هذا الرجل الذي جاء الى رئاسه حزب
الشعب الجمهوري في عام 2010 بديلا لديميز
بايكال
لكي يحقق الانتصار بنسبه الكال خسر الكثير
من الانتخابات جاهد الرجل وكانت الاعمال
معقوده عليه لكي يتمكن من الانتصاب لكنه
عاد وفشل في انتر وهذه المحاوله ربما ان
تكون الاخيره وفقا لكثير من المراقبين بعد
هذا الانتصار الكبير للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان